yes
how were you guys feeling because you
guys look amazing thank you wow we are
in so much pain
our bodies but like leading up to like
the actual live show was easy i feel
like but then it's just the rehearsing
and doing it over and over again poor
cody had to lift my butt up in the air
and so you know it's i think our body is
starting to shut down you know so but
like right now i feel
relieved yeah a sense of relief but then
a sense of sadness too because it's over
so yeah sweet i feel great i feel great
i think i i did exactly what i wanted to
come here and do and
like inspire other people to be
authentic and be themselves and to live
out loud and to be fearless so that's
exactly what i feel like i did because
this was a scary
journey you know just it's it's it's a
lot to take in so i hope i've inspired
people to do things that scare them yeah
is that the most memorable for you i
love it i love it i also want to know
will you be getting her
yes we will talk about that
we're going to get our treadmill for the
love of god yeah i won't do that for a
while so just no no no not a break but
we're going to give that treadmill for
the home so yes and thoughts on iman
winning oh
listen i i said this to my friends i was
like if i don't win i want him on to win
so i think he's great he's grown so much
he's just such a joy to watch and people
you know i love people that we want to
root for and i think iman is someone
that we want to root for and we'd love
to see those people succeed yeah
yeah you guys are so welcome thank you
so much friends
you